We finished the theoretical argument for the security of RSA.
Now I'm going to talk about some ways that things can go wrong when RSA is used in practice.
Our security argument assumed that m was a large random number.
What happens if m is small?
Assume n is some large unfactored number.
RSA-1024 is one of the unsolved RSA challenges.
We'll pick e as 17, and e is often a small number.
It doesn't inherently become insecure when we pick a small e.
The advantage to picking a small e is that it makes encryption fast.
You've intercepted the ciphertext below.
You'll be able to get that number in the Python ID,
so you don't have to try to copy it correctly.
The question is what is m?
Can you determine it from that number?